[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight not trying to be cruel
this wednesday just reading the numbers
joe biden is the most unpopular
president that the united states has had
in a very long time and voters dislike
kamala harris even more
and that's a problem because this is
supposed to be the new administration's
honeymoon period the part where everyone
thinks they're great
so it's not getting better from here
this is as beloved as the biden
administration is going to get
smart democrats can read the numbers
they understand this and they're working
on a solution
this week two of them wrote a piece in
the wall street journal calling on the
party to support hillary clinton for
president in 2024. hillary is the best
position candidate to win a national
election they argued she's also they
noted
younger than joe biden
former president bill clinton agrees
with this or says he does anyway bill
clinton told people magazine that his
wife is quote the most qualified person
to run for office in my lifetime
including me
in fact failing to elect hillary in 2016
was in bill clinton's study destination
an historic national tragedy quote one
of the most profound mistakes we've ever
made
unforgivable really the good news is we
now have a chance to correct that
mistake and you don't get those very
often in life
typically when you do something rash or
stupid you've got to live with the
consequences it's probably happened to
you one night you're listening to born
to run after too many drinks the next
thing you know you've got bruce
springsteen's face tattooed on your
lower back
it's embarrassing it's also permanent
think of hillary clinton as america's
national tattoo remover she alone can
erase the stain of our youthful bad
judgment god bless that woman
but wait a second you say hillary can't
win she's yesterday's candidate this
country's got a short attention span we
want the new new thing and hillary
clinton isn't new she's been around
forever we're bored of her
well if you believe that you don't
remember hillary clinton very well call
her what you will but she's not boring
hillary's like a box of cracker jacks or
your emotionally volatile niece who goes
to art school she's full of surprises
you never know what you're going to get
there are days when hillary seems like a
sensible midwestern methodist who grew
up republican in a suburb outside
chicago that's the biographically
accurate hillary clinton but it's hardly
the only hillary clinton during the year
she spent in arkansas for example
hillary often played the loyal daughter
of the american south a southern fried
dixie lady with a spunky feminist twist
that was the character she was
portraying when we first met her 30
years ago this month it was during the
1992 presidential primaries listen to
her accent here
you're looking at two people who love
each other this is not an arrangement or
an understanding
this is a marriage that's a very
different thing
you know i'm not sitting here as some
little woman standing by my man like
tammy wynette i'm sitting here because i
love him and i respect him and i honor
what he's been through and what we've
been through together
you don't hear a hint of parkridge
illinois in that voice it's all bourbon
and okra pretty impressive but that's
hardly the only persona in hillary's
quiver she contains multitudes when she
feels like it hillary can transform
herself entirely from a middle-aged rich
white lady to a weary but dignified
household domestic turned civil rights
protester bruised and battered from a
harrowing march across the edmund pettus
bridge on the road to freedom
sometimes hillary clinton is just sick
and tired of being sick and tired
i don't feel no ways tired
i come too far
from where i started from
nobody told me that the road would be
easy
i don't believe he brought me this far
to leave me
[Applause]
it's not a bad impression
of course there are other days when
hillary doesn't talk at all that's in
her repertoire too she just points her
finger at you and cackles wildly like a
mental patient on the subway for the
uninitiated it can be a disconcerting
experience is she casting a spell is she
going to bite me you're never sure but
her staff isn't worried they think it's
all part of her secret sauce it's one of
the reasons everyone loves hillary
here's the cackle routine
wouldn't it be insane of you to run for
office again
is she sitting across from me right
now i don't know why that's funny i mean
did you have any in-person briefings i
don't find it funny at all
how did you kill jeffrey epstein
it is
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean
really yes it deserves a lot of laughter
no she didn't kill jeffrey i've seen
remember all that
you're starting to see how the hillary
clinton phenomenon began in the first
place and why it could so easily
rekindle hillary's political career was
always a grassroots movement a prairie
fire if you will she had famously
brought support from top dnc officials
to several billionaire democratic donors
ron berkel came out for hillary that's
like winning every voter in the state of
ohio at least from a fundraising
perspective so clearly she's got the
mechanics down how about the issues
what's hillary going to run on come on
think about it libya she's going to run
on what she did in the north african
nation of libya it's the one achievement
of her life that's uniquely hers her
husband had nothing to do with it as
secretary of state under obama hillary
clinton ordered the killing of moammar
gadhafi he was the bloodthirsty libyan
strong man who was also let's be honest
creepy and weird and therefore deserving
of death
hillary had him offed
then she laughed about it watch
that is the land of unconfirmed radius
we came we saw he died
did it have anything to do with your
visit no i'm sure it did
we came we saw he died
pretty funny but then what happened
once hillary killed the leader of the
country how'd the country do
well let's see we'll tell the story in
pictures here's the capital of libby
before hillary clinton decide to
introduce the libyan people to a little
thing we call human rights
the city looks fine but underneath there
was no freedom there were too few
soros-backed ngos she changed that
now here's that same city post-hillary
those people in the foreground are
african slaves they're being sold as
property in the now thriving slave
markets in downtown tripoli
no they don't look very happy that's
true but at least qaddafi's gone so on
some level they're free they've been
liberated by hillary clinton despite the
fact they're now enslaved that's called
progress it's worth something
in fact it's a pretty good campaign
slogan hillary 2024 she'll do for us
what she did for libya you can imagine
the posters and t-shirts and coffee mugs
somebody's going to need to get those
slaves to sign a consent form put that
on the list but all of a sudden hillary
clinton for president starting to sound
a little less crazy isn't it
in fact it's starting to sound
inevitable
there are just two questions left to
answer why did hillary lose last time
and who would she run against two years
from now let's take the first question
first it's got the simplest most obvious
answer hillary clinton was cheated out
of her rightful destiny in 2016 because
unseen forces of evil worked furiously
to undermine her because they feared her
strength and goodness
come on
you knew that hillary clinton certainly
knows that watch
the russians
let's say wikileaks same thing dumped
the
john podesta emails i have my
complaints about
former director comey the use of my
email account was
turned into you know the biggest scandal
since lord knows when they covered it
like it was pearl harbor if you look at
facebook
uh the vast majority of the news news
items posted were fake there's all these
stories about you know guys over in
macedonia who are running these fake
news sites i inherit nothing from the
democratic party i also think i was the
victim of a very broad assumption i was
going to win you know if the election
been on october 27th i'd be your
president and it wasn't it was on
october 28th and there was just a lot of
funny business going on around that
so the russians wikileaks jim comey
facebook democratic party saboteurs and
the citizenry of macedonia those are the
people who did the funny business that
was like pearl harbor that prevented
hillary from becoming president that's
who opposed her last time obviously
who's going to oppose her this time
well for the answer to that question we
turn as we always do to mr tom friedman
of the new york times who is both a
pulitzer prize winner and a certified
in that paradoxical way that's familiar
to washingtonians tom friedman is just
dumb enough to get a lot of things right
if tom friedman thinks it chances are a
lot of other self-important mediocrities
think it too and those are the people
who run this country
yesterday tom friedman wrote a piece
calling on joe biden to replace kamala
harris with liz cheney in the next
election now if you're not tom friedman
or his friends this might strike you as
ridiculous in fact it might seem like
yet another sign that our political
class has reached peak decadence and
exhaustion
if they're pushing a cheney in the next
presidential cycle maybe they've run out
of ideas well of course they have and
that's exactly what gives hillary such a
natural opening here as long as we're
turning our politics into a 1990 sitcom
reunion why not get george w bush to run
that's not a crazy idea he's got the
time to do it at this stage bush would
much rather run with hillary than
against hillary their personal friends
on most things they agree vehemently but
having a bush and a clinton on the same
ticket wouldn't work it's just too
obvious
maybe w could be convinced to take one
for the establishment and throw on the
republican jersey one last time
he's 75 but that is a full presidential
term younger than joe biden which by
current standards qualifies as fresh new
leadership george w 2024 time to give
the younger generation a chance it might
work or not just spitballing here
either way it is way past time to get
hillary back into the white house the
ladies got a speech to give
she wrote it five years ago for her
inevitable inauguration thanks to the
macedonians that didn't happen but she
never threw it away she still got the
speech
last month she read a portion of it on
nbc news watch
i dream of going up to her
and sitting down next to her
taking her in my arms
and saying look at me
listen to me
you will survive
you will have a good family of your own
and three children
and as hard as it might be to imagine
your daughter will grow up and become
the president of the united states
who's she crying for herself
in case you're confused by the context
there that was hillary telling her
deceased mother that everything's going
to be okay because hillary has been
elected president of the united states
no more tears no more anxiety we're
going to make it we've got a woman in
the white house
a lot's happened since hillary clinton
wrote those words it's a different
country now than it was five years ago
but hillary clinton hasn't changed her
primary interests remain exactly what
they always were she's still talking
with endless and undimmed enthusiasm
about herself
we don't know what's in the rest of her
victory speech we're going to have to
wait until january of 2025 to find out
but one thing we can safely assume it
ends with a cackle and a finger
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else